[موسيقى]
بحيره مالحه في وسط البحر تسبح مع خمسه
ملايين قنديل بحر ولا يجيك شيء
هذه تجربه مره حلوه وانصح فيها بقوه
[موسيقى]
احنا بس نسمع قنديل البحر نخاف
فمجرد انه الواحد يفكر انه في قنديل البحر
شيء مرعب فلما عرفت انه في ملايين من
قنانير البحر تقدر تسبح معاها ابطلع من
منطقه الراحه
[موسيقى]
الجميع يعرف انه القناديل البحر لدعتها
ممكن تكون مميته على حسب نوع القنديل ولكن
سبحان الله كيف تشكلت الجزر اللي في بلاوي
بعد العصر الجليدي شكلت كذا جزر واتحوطت
فيها هذه القناه البحر هم نوعين من طبيعي
للبحر سبحان الله وتحوطوا هناك ولا يقدروا
يطلعون ولا معاهم اي حيوانات مفترسه مع
مرور الزمن فقد احساس انه ينفع فقد احساس
انه يكون سام فما عاد يعرف اكتشفنا احنا
كبشر العلم وتطورنا وعرفنا انه نقدر نسبح
معاها ولا يصير في شيء
[موسيقى]
انك توقع لا تعهد بيئي اول ما توصل هذه
المبادره جدا جميله من دوله قلاوي من
اوائل الدول اللي بادرت في هذا الشيء اللي
حافظوا على طبيعتهم يحافظ على البيئه وحتى
الى درجه انك لما تسبح مع قناديل البحر
ممنوع انك تحط اللوشن او ممنوع انك تحط
واقي شمس
طبعا جزيره ايلي مالك اللي فيها قناديق
البحر تبعد ساعه بالقارب من الجزيره
الرئيسيه اللي عايشين فيها 70% من سكان
دوله الجزيره هذه بعد ما توصل لازم تسوي
هاي كينج عشرين دقيقه عشان توصل الى
البحيره المالحه اللي في نص البحر كذا
سبحان الله
[موسيقى]